pack your bags because you're traveling
through space to see Alpha Centauri
there's just one problem it's going to
take 100 years
is it at least possible to sleep on the
trip
well yeah but get comfy because you're
going nighty night for an entire century
what technology would you need
what would happen to your body while
you're asleep
and what sort of stuff could be waiting
for you in the future
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you hibernated for 100 years
so what is hibernation exactly
you know besides a really long nap
well it's a prolonged resting state that
animals enter during winter months or
when food gets scarce
during hibernation an animal's body
temperature heart rate and Metabolism
decrease
a lot that's because the animal's body
enters a torpor state it's a deep sleep
when the animal is almost entirely
inactive
you know like me at the end of the day
now look I don't blame you for wanting
to sleep through the winter but 100
years in space is another story entirely
and how would you even pull it off
first you'd have to induce hibernation
which might get tricky you see lowering
human body temperature is harder than
you think
researchers think that because of our
body mass we wouldn't be able to lower
our body temperature to zero degrees
Celsius as rodents do
turns out we're more like bears as our
temperature only declines slightly but
you might have a workaround have you
heard of the process called Cooling
hospitals use it to slow down or stop
the body's functions during some
surgeries
ice packs coolers or even a cooled
saline solution directly injected into
your blood can lower your temperature
then you enter that torpor state we
talked about before
but here's the problem
we can only cool humans for 14 days tops
so how do we keep you nice and cozy for
the other thirty six thousand
when you freeze ice crystals form deep
inside your cells once formed these cell
cycles can rupture and cause permanent
damage
to get around this we'll need to bring
out the big guns
cryogenics this process involves
replacing your regular body fluids with
an anti-freezing agent and you know what
it might work
scientists have used this technology to
freeze and more importantly unfreeze 50
millimeters of tissue without causing
any damage
okay let's say we've got a cryogenic
setup on the ship
would it allow you to survive your 100
Year Journey
well research shows that animals who
spend more time hibernating tend to live
longer
so yeah hibernation could slow aging
if that's the case you'd wake up in a
new century
technology would have advanced societies
would have evolved and the environment
would have changed when you woke up
you'd be in a completely different world
that you may not recognize or understand
think about it in the last 100 years we
saw the invention of talking movies
penicillin helicopters nuclear bombs
credit cards seat belts computers and
the internet
wait when were seat belts invented wow
1959 so we created the nuclear bomb
before seat belts
okay
a lot of stuff will change and the Earth
won't be exactly like you remember it if
there still is an earth as climate
change continues more and more
environmental disasters will occur
before you went into hibernation you
were going to travel to another planet
well at least you won't have to deal
with earth's climate change I guess
but if I'm being honest I don't think
you'd survive the trip
you are just not built for it
your body doesn't have the same
physiological adaptations that allow
animals to maintain a state of torpor in
reality attempting to hibernate like an
animal could be super dangerous
for example a bear eats a large amount
of food before hibernating which allows
it to store enough energy to survive the
winter
if you tried to do the same thing your
artery walls would thicken and give you
a big list of health problems
a bear can remain completely still for
months but you would lose muscle mass
and strength after just a week or two of
inactivity this is why bedridden
patients often suffer from muscle
atrophy and weakness
Okay so we've still got some work to do
before you can pull this off
we humans just aren't made to sleep that
long
but what if you took that as a personal
challenge
what if you stopped sleeping entirely
[Music]
well that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]